My name is David. I'm a PhD student from
Sat's lab. And uh my background is
probably a bit different than yours
because I studied biology initially and
then I went to industry and worked for a
couple of years as a weblab protein
engineer and then I did a second
master's degree in data science before I
came back to ETH um to join sits lab as
a PhD and I'm mainly working on
um machine learning for drug discovery
and generative AI for for drug discovery
as well.
and I will talk today about some
applications of AI in chemistry and
biology. Um, this is a super dynamic
field. It has experienced a couple of
breakthroughs in the recent years. Um,
and I will just try to give you an
overview over the current state of the
field, what is happening, what are the
models that are most frequently used.
But of course this will be by no means
an an exhaustive uh overview over the
field because it will be focused on
structural biology, protein folding and
drug discovery uh also drug design but
of course that leaves out many
applications. Um, and also if I show you
an example for a model, this might not
be necessarily because it's the best
model there is, but maybe because it's
the the most instructive one or maybe
the the first one that um existed of its
kind. So in these cases, I've usually
added these beyond today's scope uh
slides that are just for those who are
interested. Um pointing to other models
that are maybe um newer, maybe more
sophisticated, more successful. Um yes,
so this is
the outline of today. At the beginning I
will just give you short introduction to
proteins and small molecules that we are
all on the same page and then I will um
transition to the first kind of machine
learning model those that are based on
sequence representations of proteins and
small molecules. Then I would also like
to to speak about structure based models
that use uh 3D structures. Uh but before
I do that I I will uh introduce
structure prediction models such as
Alpha Fall 2 and DSM and then probably
next week I will mention or talk a bit
about some challenges of training
machine learning models on biological
data and then um start the whole chapter
about generative models for um the no
design of proteins and small molecules.
If you have any questions generally just
uh raise your hand or write into the
chat that's no problem. So in the first
section of the talk I will just give
this short introduction to proteins and
small molecules because I think many of
of you don't have a biology background
at all. Um and we need this basics for
all the models that come later.
So small molecules are organic compounds
that have usually less than 100 atoms.
Um so they are quite small and because
of this um they can diffuse across cell
membranes and they can enter cells. Um
many organisms produce such small
molecules naturally as metabolites or
signaling molecules like this cortisol
that you can see here that is a stress
hormone. And these molecules often
interact with proteins and influence
their function. And that's why most
drugs are small molecules also because
they can enter the cells through the
cell membranes usually um for example
the the aspirin molecule is also of this
kind and the structure of these small
molecules usually allows them because
they are relatively small um allows to
synthesize them in the chemical lab
quite easily.
Then proteins are these uh chain-like
organic molecules that are much larger
and they are built of a fixed set of
building blocks. So they are chains that
fold into a defined 3D structure known
as this native confirmation. So it might
be a bit hard to see um here in this
figure
but this is a chain that just that takes
up this three-dimensional structure in
and then forms this um globular um form
that you can see here by this uh surface
approximation
and
this um 3D structure of the protein then
also defines its function. So these
proteins can be enzymes for example that
catalyze some chemical reactions. They
can be structural component signaling
molecules and generally they are just
extremely important and basically
necessary for every um process um
involved in life basically.
And as I said, all proteins are made of
this fixed set of building blocks that
we call amino acids. And there are 20
standard amino acids as you can see here
on the right side. And they are the
fundamental building blocks of all
proteins.
And they have a backbone in common. So
what you can see in each amino acid is
this triangle of this N, this C atom and
this C atom here. So these are basically
this amino group and this caroxil group
and they are the links of the chain. So
if we connect these building blocks
these amino acids into a protein then
it's these triangles that connect and
form this linear chain.
And what differentiates the amino acids
is just what is ext what is attached to
this atom here the C alpha atom and
that's also different for each amino
acid and it's what defines the chemical
properties of the amino acids
and another fact that shows how
important proteins are is that our DNA
um encodes for the precise sequence of
proteins of the amino acids in proteins.
So each triplet of DNA nucleotides um
encodes for a specific amino acids. So
when uh this DNA is transcribed to RNA
and then then it's translated to um to a
chain of amino acids and once this chain
here is uh synthesized
um it starts folding um into this more
ordered three-dimensional structure
which is defined which defines the
protein's biological function
afterwards.
And this folded structure is defined by
the sequence of the amino acids alone.
So the folding is kind of a spontaneous
uh process of energy minimization that
is guided by these interactions between
the amino acids and their side chains
such as hydrophobic interactions or
hydrogen bonds.
And then in a protein structure we have
these three levels of uh
three structural levels. The first is
just the the primary structure that
refers to the sequence of the amino
acids in in this chain. And then the
secondary structure um describes these
regularly repeating local structures
that are stabilized by hydrogen bonds.
Um the most common examples are um these
alpha helyses and these beta sheets that
appear um really frequently. And then
the tertiary structure uh refers to the
spatial relationship of these secondary
structure elements um to each other
then you will really often see yes
>> in the same sequence.
>> No. So the same sequence cannot um end
up in different tertiary structures. Um
so it will always have the generally the
same fold. But of course proteins are um
dynamic. So they don't always uh have
exactly the same structure. So the the
fold is the same but they are constantly
moving. And there are some proteins that
are more dynamic. They have some loops
that can um like change their position.
So that's why there are also MD
simulations to simulate the dynamics of
a protein. So you might see different
configurations of the same protein but
generally same sequence always results
into the same fold.
The primary structures determines
secondary.
>> Sorry again.
>> So the primary struct structure determs
the both the secondary and the
>> Yes. Exactly.
And you will really often see these
proteins in this cartoon depiction.
Um and this is just to show the location
um of the backbone and the these u
characteristic secondary structure
elements. But as I said, it only shows
where the backbone is of the protein. So
if you would show the side chains of the
amino acids, so the extensions attached
to the tip of all these triangles that
form the chain, then it would look a bit
messier. So
now let's turn our attention to the
engineering of proteins and small
molecules.
So if we talk about engineering of small
molecules um we have to know that
they usually bind to proteins and affect
their biological some biological process
and the chemical structure and the
composition of the small molecules
defines its function and also its
binding preferences.
So small molecules are usually
engineered to interact with a specific
target and then to modulate the
associated disease pathway. So this can
be to inhibit an enzyme or to block a
receptor. An example would be this
aspirin molecule that binds to the cylo
oxygenase enzyme which would otherwise
form prostaglandins and cause fever and
inflammation.
So
engineering of small molecules is kind
of altering the size and the composition
of the organic compound by like adding a
different carbon backbone or change some
functional group to get desired
properties and binding preferences
and the engineering of proteins is all
about changing the amino acid sequence
to achieve a specific function or
property. So in the field of
biocatalysis you could for example say
that um you want to change the amino
acid sequence of the protein so that it
can it can accept the new substrate. Um
so for example here if you have this
this protein in cartoon depiction here
which is an enzyme and you wanted to to
accommodate this substrate you might uh
have to change these uh locations in the
sequence so that this this process can
happen and this small molecule of this
substrate can be catalyzed.
And then in the context of therapeutics,
you could think of an amino acid uh
sequence of an antibbody that you change
in some way that it will bind to to
source cof 2 spike protein for example.
There's a couple of strategies for
protein engineering. So there's rational
design and semi-rational design. And
rational design is just uh that you use
very detailed knowledge of your protein
of your system um to make desired
changes very simple. So
you might know that um for this enzyme
here to bind the substrate these
positions in the chain are probably
important. So you might think that this
one here needs some charged amino acid
so that this substrate can bind more
efficiently
and that would be rational design. And
semi-rational design would be for
example that you just introduce sites
that are probably important for a
specific process and then you just
exchange the amino acids at all these
sites to all possible amino acids
creating a combinatorial library. Then
you try out all all the variants
basically
and then there's uh the strategy of
directed evolution which is um
quite uh successful in my opinion. It
also got a Nobel Prize a couple of years
ago and it works by introducing random
mutations. Then you get a pool of
mutants and then you test all these
mutants. You pick out those that are
most performant and you restart the
whole process. So it's kind of
accelerated evolution and it's quite
um successful in making a protein better
at the function that it already has. So
it require usually requires a protein
that is already um working in some way
but you would like to improve it. So you
can do direct evolution and this quite
successful usually but all theseh
strategies are quite time consuming and
expensive and are generally only uh
suited for optimizing existing proteins.
And the main um difficulty of protein
engineering is this vast size of the of
the search space. So if you um consider
that there are 20 naturally occurring
amino acids um each of which can occupy
any position in a protein chain then a
protein of just 100 amino acids has 20
to the power of 100 possible sequences
right and uh natural proteins are
usually a bit longer than 100 amino
acids like a couple of hundred or
thousands um
so that's where like AI and machine
learning models come in they are
supposed to help us to to navigate this
search space a bit better and to narrow
down the space of possible solutions.
And
that brings us to the first um type of
model which is models that operate on
sequences.
So I'll just introduce the sequence
representations that we use for proteins
and small molecules and then I will give
you some examples of uh machine learning
models.
Okay, so protein in sequence
representation is quite straightforward.
It's just um letters representing the
amino acids in the chain. So, and then
for as you can see it here and then for
machine learning um these amino acid
sequences are just encoded into some
numerical representations with maybe one
hot encoding or some tokenization where
each amino acid is is treated as a
separate token like in in text
processing.
And then in small molecules this is a
bit more complicated. What what people
often use are these smile strings. So
it's a linear notation that represents
the molecular structure of a chem of a
small molecular compound using using
characters. So as you can see here atoms
are usually represented by their
chemical symbol. Single bonds are are
omitted but the double bonds are
depicted by these equal signs
and branches are described using these
parentheses and rings are noted using uh
the numbers indicating their attend
their um connection points.
And then for machine learning these
smiles codes are also tokenized and
fixed to a to a fixed vocabulary.
Um
you've probably noted already this
sounds like natural language processing
and these methods um indeed had like a
big impact on the field because there's
this analogy between the building blocks
of language and those of proteins and
small molecules. So like in natural
language you could think of protein
sequence having their own kind of
grammar and they also contain long range
dependencies. So for example, amino
acids would would correspond to words,
sequences of amino acids to um sentences
and then protein would be an entire text
paragraph for example.
And also um in smiles codes for small
molecules, it's it's the same. It's also
linear sequences that consist of a fixed
vocabulary of symbols and there are
patterns and rules to it.
So both these representations are
compatible with um NLP methods and that
are designed to handle such sequences.
So and the first application of uh NLP
to proteins was this evolutionary scale
modeling the ESM model trained by MEA.
Um, and it's a a self-supervised
language model trained with this masked
language modeling objective
um, and trained on 250 million protein
sequences. So it works in this way that
you have this native sequence and then
you change it by corrupting a small
fraction of the amino acids with a mask
and then using this corrupted sequence
you encode it into numerical
representation
and then this ESM model very simplified
here translates this numerical
representation into some latent space
representation some hidden state
representation that allows it to make a
prediction for which amino acids have
been masked in the original sequence.
And if this prediction is wrong, then
the model is improved and that's how it
is trained.
And it turns out that
um filling gaps in protein sequences is
a very simple task, but it's not easy at
all. So you can imagine that you need a
lot of knowledge about proteins to be
able to do that and also knowledge about
how proteins
like form a 3D shape for example because
at some locations in the 3D structure of
the protein some amino acids might have
space to fit there and some might not.
So it turned out that knowledge of
intrinsic properties of the proteins
emerges in these latent sp lat latent
space representations without any
supervision. And this knowledge is as I
said encoded in this hidden state
representations
and the authors they showed this using
ortologist groups of genes. So um genes
that come from the same ancestral
protein but maybe in different species.
So um these orthologist groups they
usually have a similar function but not
necessarily the same sequence.
So what the authors showed is that the
untrained transformer if you pass these
sequence where where all an autotologist
group is depicted by some some color um
and the untrained transformer just
doesn't really add a structure to these
sequences right but then the trained
transformer is able to group these
orthologist groups into clusters in this
uh tney two-dimensional representation
here. So um this shows us that the model
kind of learned to um group different
sequences together based on
their shared common function basically
and these hidden state representations
of this such a transformer model like
ESM um they are used frequently for
transfer learning. So for example,
people fine-tune these protein language
models on specific downstream tasks um
even with a potentially quite small
labeled data set um for example for the
applications like protein function
prediction or um prediction of
mutational effects and also for the
prediction of the protein 3D structure
as we will see later. Yeah. And these
pre-trained transformer embeddings they
are now used in in many downstream
applications.
And
first slide for those of you who are
interested what I haven't been speaking
about now is that there are a lot of uh
chemistry language models that work the
same way with this mask language model
objective but they are trained on these
smile strings representing small
molecules
and they all in some way demonstrate
chemical learning either by just being
able to recover the masked smiles tokens
or by clustering ing molecules by
chemical features in the latence based
representations or just by improving
downstream molecular property prediction
um performance for example and the
examples for this would be um this mole
former model from IBM IBM research or
the cambera model but there are many
many more
so the next section of the talk will
focus on a special kind of
sequence-based models uh namely the
protein structure prediction models like
uh this includes alpha fold 2 and also
second version of this ESM model and
then in the end I will also briefly
touch upon these uh new folding models
that don't just predict the structure of
a single protein but of entire molecular
assemblies.
But first um about protein structure.
Very simply put, it just refers to the
3D coordinates of all atoms of the
protein in its folded state.
And knowing the protein structure is
very important because it gives us some
fundamental understanding of a protein
and it gives us also an idea what what
could be its its function because
structure of a protein defines its
function, right? And then for drug
discovery um knowing the protein
structure might for example help us to
identify some um active sites or
interaction points for potential drug
molecules. So you might maybe see this
protein here and then detect that there
is this groove with some interactive
amino acid side chains that you might
use to attack this protein uh using a
small molecule drug
and
to get protein structures. Um for many
years researchers relied on these very
time consuming methods like X-ray
crystalallography or NMR um to get just
get the structure of a single protein
and recently deep learning has kind of
taken over structure prediction and
this is quite remarkable because um
predicting the 3D fold of a protein um
is an extremely difficult and
challenging task. And this is because
these amino acid residues they can adopt
so many configurations due to the
rotations around their backbone bonds
and side chains that even a tiny protein
has like an astronomical number of
potential configurations.
So the folding is also driven by these
various interactions that are quite
diffic diff difficult to model such as
hydrogen bonds and hydrophobic
interactions
and there are also these long range
dependencies.
So the folding is influenced by
interactions between amino acids that
are far apart in the sequence of the
protein but then come into close
vicinity in the 3D structure.
And then last but not least, the
training data is relatively scarce.
Although thousands of researchers have
crystallized proteins for decades, um
the total number of crystallized protein
structures is still relatively small
from a deep learning perspective.
And because this task is so difficult
but also so important, there was this uh
critical assessment of protein structure
prediction challenge. So it's a an event
that took place every second year
um where research groups were invited to
submit their models and then these
structure prediction models would be
tested on a on a set of uh
experimentally solved structures that
haven't been released or published yet.
And Alpha 2 um developed by um DeepMind
it won the the 14th holding of this
challenge. And as you can see here, it
it won with quite a big margin compared
to its competitor models uh that also
took part in a challenge. And the
predictions of on this uh unpublished
set of um protein structures that were
made by alphafold they were really
precise. um the deviation of the C alpha
atoms. So the tips of these backbone
triangles that every amino acid has the
deviation was only about 0.96.
So that is really precise as as
comparison the um size of a carbon atoms
about 1.4 angstroms.
This is was really a breakthrough in the
field of structural binomatics
and
that's why I will now dive a little bit
deeper into the architecture of alpha 2
but it will still remain quite quite
high level because it's a rather
complicated model um but I will give my
best. So the input to the model is the
sequence of the protein obviously and
then what the model does is it it
accesses the genetic database looking
for um similar sequences in other
organisms and then it forms this
multiple sequence alignment that
contains a lot of information about um
evolutionary con um conservation of
certain sites in the proteins
And
then it also uh uses a structure
database search to look for um
structures of similar proteins that
might already exist. And based on this
uh it makes a first guess of the pair
wise distances of the amino acids in
this protein.
And then this MSA representation based
on the multiple sequence alignment and
this pair representation.
um they are passed into this uh
evoiformer model that is the core of the
architecture of alpha fold and this
updates the two representations through
some tension mechanisms and convolution
like operations.
Um and then these updated
representations they are passed into
this structure module that just converts
this um into spatial coordinates. So it
predicts the makes a final prediction on
the pair-wise distances between the res
residue pairs and also the angles of the
bonds in the protein and generally just
constructs a 3D model of the protein
and it also applies this interesting
concept of recycling. So that's this
iterative refinement process where the
output of the structure module here is
passed back multiple times into this
evoformer.
Um and apparently this helps to refine
the predictions by allowing the network
kind of to to reconsider its earlier
outputs.
So apparently the model benefits from
this additional contextual information
that it gets from subsequent layers.
training of alpha fold works with a a
structure objective obviously so just
the deviation from the true structure is
is penalized and then there's a a
secondary birth objective that operates
on the MSA on the multiple sequence
alignment and the network is required to
reconstruct some masked regions of this
multiple sequence alignment
representation
and then training also involves this uh
self distillation uh princip principle
that I find quite interesting. So how
this works is that there's this phase of
initial supervised training that you
just train on the data set of known
experimentally solved protein structures
uh using conventional supervised machine
learning with these objectives that I
showed above and then once the model has
achieved a certain level you use it to
make predictions for the structures of
350,000
additional sequences for which no
structure exists yet. And then they
mixed these experimental structures and
the predictions of this preliminary
model and trained the model from scratch
using this mix of data. And apparently
that makes such effective use of
unlabeled sequences and makes the
training data set so much more diverse
that this overall improves the accuracy
of the model which I find quite quite
interesting.
Is it okay if we take a break now? Then
continue with the next model after the
break. Okay.
So, are you ready to continue?
Now, I would like to remind you of this
model that I showed you earlier, this
ESM model, the self-supervised
transformer language model trained on
these 250 million protein sequences.
Um
and as we said the a lot of knowledge
about protein properties is embedded in
this hidden state representation
and the authors also showed that um
while this model cannot observe the
protein structure directly
um and the the structure is kind of like
a hidden variable that influences the
pattern that the model sees in the
sequences. So they showed that this
unsupervised pre-training also encodes
some secondary structure into the
representation
and they did this very easily. They just
u took a data set of proteins with a
known structure and added labels to each
amino acid um indicating whether they
are part of a helix or a strand or a
coil. Here you can see this in the
corresponding colors.
And then they just derived this
transformer latent space representation
for each of these proteins or for each
amino acid of these proteins. And then
they fit a logistic regression
classifier to predict the secondary
structure membership um from this hidden
state representation. And they get a
high accuracy from this showing that um
this self-supervised training indeed um
generates and embed structural knowledge
in this transformer representation.
And that's why in a in a second version
of the model um the ESM model is
extended with a folding head to predict
atomic coordinates and they use this
pre-trained ESM model based on the
machine uh the masked language model
objective and just add this folding hat
that extracts uh atomic coordinates from
this hidden state representations and
then they train this and they fine-tune
it end to end on about the same training
data that alpha fold
and um like all the experimentally
determined structures from the protein
data bank. And then with this they
achieved the structure prediction
accuracy quite similar to alpha fold
and this is remarkable um because this
strategy kind of removes the most costly
aspects of alpha fold. Uh so for example
this multiple sequence alignment and
that speeds it up about 60fold
uh according to the authors and it's
also completely standalone so it doesn't
need to access databases of known
structures or um evolutionary databases
with related sequences. Um so it just
takes a protein sequences and then
outputs the structure of it.
And then if you wonder what kind of
model um that you want to use for your
protein uh structure prediction, you can
see like an example comparison here
between crystal structure and ESM
prediction and an alpha fold prediction.
And we have to split this evaluation in
backbone atoms. So those the triangles
that are the links of the chain and side
chain atoms because the the backbone
atoms are generally um easier to to
find. So both models perform well but
alpha fold is often still leading a bit
in direct comparisons.
And then if we um talk about side chain
atoms, the precision of both models
drops a bit because um these side chains
are very flexible and therefore harder
to predict. But alpha fold generally
performs a bit better in modeling the
positions of these side chains. Uh so if
you have some application where high
accuracy in backbone and side chains is
crucial then you would probably use
alpha fold. Um but ESM fold is um
nevertheless super valuable especially
if you need quick predictions um maybe
for a vast number of protein sequences
but generally um protein structures are
now much easier to obtain. I would like
to um
demonstrate that uh briefly.
So the the authors of the ESM paper um
they have just decided to bold 770
million proteins even proteins that um
maybe not don't even exist in reality.
So they made this metagenomic atlas
where you have all these proteins in
this two-dimensional representation.
Then you can explore this here. And
every point in this uh
um cluster represents a protein and the
yellow ones are proteins that are were
previously unknown and the blue ones are
proteins that were maybe already
characterized a bit earlier. Um but this
is very impressive that they just uh the
model they just used it to predict 770
million protein structures and you can
look at each of them and download the
the PDB file and structure file for it.
Now that we have covered the like two
protein folding models uh I would like
to move on to some uh
recent development of the co-folding
models. So models that don't just um
predict the structure of a single
protein but predict an the structure of
an entire assembly. Um so this could be
could look um like this for example.
So as you know proteins they they rarely
act alone. Um they usually form
complexes with other proteins or small
molecules DNA and RNA. And recent
folding models, they also include these
biomolelecules, these others um and form
kind of an unified structure prediction
tool that predicts this entire assembly
with nucleic acids or metal ions or also
small molecules.
So examples for this would be Rosetta
fold all atom and alpha fold 3. So this
Rosetta fold all atom is this threetrack
neural network um developed by the the
Baker lab in University of Washington
that predicts these structures of of of
biomolecular assemblies. So it's trained
now on a on a mixed data set of of
biomolelecules including also protein
small molecule interactions or protein
metal complexes
um or even protein DNA interactions.
Right? So the input to this model is not
just the protein sequence anymore but
also a potential um DNA sequence some
some graph representations of of small
molecules or also the chemical element
type of non-polymer atom and then this
um network fuses all this information
and outputs some um potential structure
of this interaction between the entities
that you added to the input
And alpha fold does a similar thing and
it claims to have a bit higher accuracy
than rosetta fold all atom. Um and the
differences to the alphafold 2
architecture that I've showed you before
is that the input of course now includes
lians and nucleic acids and met ions. Um
but this multiple sequence alignment uh
path is is quite deemphasized.
So it's a much smaller MSA module. And
then importantly this structure module
of alpha fold 2 is replaced by by
diffusion uh model. So the diffusion
module now predicts the atom coordinates
from from this pair signal and this
input representation here.
Okay. And here as well um for those who
are interested um there are a lot of
these co-folding models developed at the
moment. So these volts models are quite
famous developed by researchers at MIT
together with recursion. They are also
diffusion based as is uh this chai one
model also predicts molecular complexes.
And then there's also the open fold
consortium which is quite interesting
because it's a nonprofit AI research and
development consortium that aims to
develop like an open uh open ecosystem
of AI tools for for biology and and drug
discovery. They also have this open fold
three um co-folding model.
Now that we have discussed the structure
prediction tools, we can transition to
models that leverage these structures as
as input data. And in this context, I
will briefly mention 3D CNN's, 3D
convolutional neural networks and then
uh also GNN models. But before I can
talk about the GNN models, um I was
asked to give an introduction to to
graphs and graph neural networks. So
that's what I will do um before we touch
upon the the GNN models.
So but first um the importance of
structure. So as you know the structure
of a protein determines its function. Uh
so the proteins they fold into these
complex shapes and interact specifically
with other molecules. So a protein
sequence alone doesn't provide
information about the actual spatial
arrangement of the atoms in 3D space. So
consider you have a task that requires
an understanding of the physical
placement of residues. Then models that
incorporate this structure information
should actually be superior. So for
example in in interaction prediction or
enzyme activity prediction and I guess
you all agree with me that if you want
to make a prediction on whether this
enzyme can bind or maybe catalyze this
substrate here um the 3D placement of
all these protein residues in this
pocket should be quite important or
quite useful at least for the prediction
of this model.
But there are also a lot of challenges
in the use of sculptural data. So it's
uh it's availability is generally much
lower and the sequence-based methods
are usually simpler and more
computationally efficient. Right?
And as I said I will briefly explain the
3D CNN's. So how these models usually
work is that they take for example a
protein structure like here and they
convert these atomic coordinates uh in a
format suitable for for 3D CNN's. So the
space around the protein is just divided
into a grid of so-called voxels and then
different atomic properties of the
underlying atoms they can be used to
define multiple channels in the input
data. For example, um the atom types of
charges. In this example here, you have
a carbon channel here and an oxygen
channel and nitrogen channel. And then
you have this convolution and ruling
layers to extract um the relevant
features and reduce the the spatial
dimension of the input. And then in the
end you have you have a fully connected
layer that deres your prediction
whatever that would be. And this 3D CNN
they have shown to perform quite well in
tasks such as protein uh the stability
prediction and also in protein liant
binding affinity. So this is about um
when you have a complex of a protein and
the small molecule you want to predict
the interaction strength. So basically
which is called the binding affinity and
the 3D CNN's they do this by by
centering a grid around the geometric
center of the liant and then they um
each position of of of the atoms within
the binding pocket uh is kind of mapped
to one of these voxels and the chemical
properties are then used to define
additional channels. So this model here
seems to have a a channel for aromatic
rings for example and then one for
hydrogen donors and some some other one.
And then again like convolutional neural
network reduces this 3D grid uh into a
single PKD value that represents a
binding affinity. And in this task, the
3D CNN's were the first structure-based
models that were shown to outperform
sequence-based affinity models.
But there there are couple of drawbacks
on using these 3D CNNs. So the model
size um they are usually
um larger than 2D CNN's because the
parameters they grow cubically with uh
the resolution of the grid and uh the
sparsity is also an issue um because
these grits that you put around proteins
they they very often contain a
significant portion of of voxels that um
contain only empty or homogeneous
regions of of the complex that does not
contribute ute any meaningful
information and there the inefficiency
arises because all these
meaningless uh grid points are still
processed by the model and then there's
the problem of the rotational invariance
um as in 2D CNN's if you want to achieve
invariant predictions uh regardless of
the orientation of the input structure
in the input data then you need to
present that object in in several
rotations.
So 3D CNN's usually require um larger
training data sets um to work well and
avoid overfitting and training and
inference usually require a lot of
memory and processing power. So the
application of the 3D CNN's to very
large data sets uh is limited. For
example, if you have a molecular dynamic
simulation and you would like to process
each frame of that simulation, then you
might profit from something that is a
bit more efficient.
And with this in mind, I would like to
transition to the introduction about
graphs and graph neural networks. and um
because these uh can solve most of these
drawbacks of the 3D CNN.
So I will start at the very basics. Um
the graphs describe just a set of
objects that we call nodes and the
connections between them that we call
edges. This would be an example here.
And then you can store information in in
the nodes of the graph or also in the
edges of the graph. And then you might
also have some global information
attached to to this entire graph. And
this is quite a powerful representation
of data especially for um naturally like
non- ukidian and unordered data. So if
you think of a social network with
friendships or citation networks or also
like atoms in a molecule and graph
neural networks they can process such
unordered graph structures.
So as I said we have these four types of
information that we want to uh use to
make predictions on this graph. So we
have the connectivity that contains a
lot of information by itself and then
the features in nodes edges and uh also
some graph level features
and molecules um are quite convenient to
model as graphs. It's it's a natural
abstraction where the the atoms of the
molecules are translated to nodes and
the bonds of the molecule are translated
to edges of the graph. And then it also
allows for integration of um chemical
properties into the node edge and global
features. So you could take this
caffeine molecule here and model it as a
graph like this. And then you can for
example add some uh chemical atom
properties into the node features
because the nodes represent the atoms of
the molecule. And then you can add
information up about the chemical bonds
to the edges. And then in the global
context you could also have whatever
information you have about this
molecule. Yeah.
And then what kind of tasks can we or
do we maybe want to solve using using
using graphs. So there's a graph level
tasks obviously that you just predict a
single property for an entire graph. So
for example you have this molecule you
model it as a graph and you want to know
um is this molecule an antibiotic. That
would be a graph level task.
And then there's a node level tasks
where you predict some property for each
node in the graph. What I show here is
just this uh famous toy data set where
you have this karate club and the two
instructures they they have an argument
and then the edges they represent the
social interactions between the members
of the club and the task is in this toy
data set to predict which of the members
stays loyal to what which instructor and
um this is a node level task because we
predict one property for each um node in
this graph
And then there's also the edge level
tasks where we predict uh the property
or the presence of an edge in the graph.
And an example for this would be the
friendship suggestions on Facebook for
example.
And
the GNN is basically a an optimizable
transformation on all these attributes
of the graph. So on the no nodes edges
and this global context but it preserves
the graph connectivity right. So they
usually adopt this um graph in graph out
architecture. They accept the graph as
input with uh information loaded into
its notes edges and maybe global context
and then they progressively transform
these um embeddings
without changing the connectivity of
this input graph.
And to update these graph features in
the nodes and edges, they usually apply
this message passing neural network
framework where um neighboring nodes and
edges exchange information to influence
each other's updated embeddings. So this
makes the learned embeddings kind of
aware of the structure of the graph and
of the neighborhood of an of a note. for
example.
And this message passing works um in a
way that for each node in a graph, we
try gather all the neighboring node
embeddings or messages like here and
then we aggregate all these messages
using aggregation function. In this
example, it's just summing them up um
but it could be other ways and we also
include the embedding of the node
itself. And then we pass these pulled
messages through an update function
which is usually a learned neural
network and then we obtain um the
updated embedding of this node. So from
this perspect from the perspective of
this single node we aggregate we collect
all these node embeddings of these
neighbors it's connected to we aggregate
them pass them through this learnable
weight matrix and then uh we have this
updated node embedding and we do this
simultaneously for all nodes in the
graph.
So and then if we want to take
predictions then uh for example for a
node level then we just take all the
node embeddings and pass them through
through a fully connected neural network
to get some predictions for each nodes
and same for edges. And if we um want to
do a graph level prediction, so for
example, is it is the molecule
antibiotic or not? Then we can use
global pooling for example to to um pool
all node embeddings into one single
representation and then pass them
through a neural network and then makes
a prediction or we can just process the
transformed global features of of the
graph.
So this has a lot in common with the
image convolution. Um both are
operations that aggregate and process
the information of an element's
neighbors to update the elements own
values. So in graphs these elements are
just nodes and in images they are they
are pixels. And um if you consider a a
graph where um
each node is connected to its
neighboring nodes and it's arranged in
this 2D array then it would be quite
similar to um image convolution.
But in uh in graphs generally the number
of uh nodes in the graph is the number
of neighboring nodes is is quite
variable and also um
the structure is of course not adhered
to. folders uh they can be very
unordered right
and that's why because of this analogy
the the message passing process in these
uh GNN is also called graph convolution
and then as in 2D um 2D CNN's with
images for example we can also stack
graph convolutional layers and then if
we have three convolutional layers all
doing message passing then every node
will contain ain information about every
node that is up to three steps away from
itself.
Then there are a couple of uh or quite
many different convolutional operators.
So
um one of the most common and most
easiest is this GCN conf where you just
uh you want to find the updated
embedding of this node I in the in the
next layer. And for this you go through
all the neighbors of this node I. You
take um
their node embeddings. you uh pass them
through through a learnable weight
matrix and you normalize by the degrees
of the nodes. Then you sum this up to
get the new embedding of this node I.
And in this attention version, it works
quite similarly. You also um take all
the neighbors of this node I, their
embeddings, you multiply them with this
weight matrix and then also an attention
uh attention score. And this is computed
based on um the embeddings of the two
nodes and the edge between them. So from
the perspective of a single node you
would kind of assign importance values
or weights to all these nodes neighbors
and this is then uh taken into account
in in this aggregation function.
So now that we have established these
GNN basics, uh we can proceed to this
examples of GNN models
um they were mainly for drug discovery.
And
the first very cool model is this GNN
that is capable of capable of predicting
molecules with antibacteridal
um antibacterial activity
and this is a graph binary
classification problem. So you have a a
molecule, you model it as a graph, you
want to take get one prediction for the
entire graph. The training set for this
model was only about 2 and a half
thousand drug molecules and among them
120 of them um are known antibiotics
and then they generate these graphs of
the molecules and they include a lot of
chemical properties into the nodes and
also into the edges of the graph and
then they do a couple of layers of this
uh convolutional layer. So growth graph
convolution
followed by global ad pooling and then
they have a feed forward neural network
that just outputs a probability of
growth inhibition of E.coli so of
antibacterial activity
and this model is quite simple
but they then used it to make
predictions. So inference on a large um
collection of uh of on the drug
repurposing hub a large collection of
small molecules and then um they saw
this really nice enrichment that among
the 99 molecules with the highest model
prediction
uh 51 of them actually displayed growth
inhibition and among the the bottom 63
they only had two molecules that
displayed growth inhibition.
So you can see that here if you have a
certain concentration of bacteria and
then you add this helicin the new
antibiotic that they discovered you add
this to to to the mix and then these
bacteria start to to die.
So they also showed that they pre-treat
the bacteria with uh what was it um
quite an old antibiotic that doesn't
work that well anymore. they um can even
kill the persisters. So though that the
bacteria that uh resisted to the
ampitine
and then they also saw that this new
antibiotic had quite a low structural
similarity to its nearest neighbor
antibiotic. So they concluded that the
model was kind of able to generalize and
access some some new antibiotic
chemistry which I think is uh quite
remarkable for this uh model.
And then another example of graph neural
networks um they are really often used
for this uh prediction of binding
affinity. So the interaction strength
between a small molecule and the protein
um using the 3D structure of this
interaction as an input. So this is
really important for for drug design
because you want this small molecule to
bind with a really high affinity to very
specific protein so that it can be a
useful drug. And the models that take
such a structure and uh assign a binding
affinity they are referred to as scoring
functions.
And classically these were um force
fieldbased or empirical or knowledge
based uh models. But unfortunately they
show quite limited accuracy in binding
affinity prediction and AI models are
now supposed to improve that.
And
an example for a model is this GEMS
model. It's quite simple and uh uh easy
to understand. It's also a graph
convolutional neural network for
predicting these binding affinities and
it's trained on PDB bind which is a
collection of um experimentally solved
protein liant complexes that have
binding affinity labels.
So if you have this interaction here of
this small molecule with this protein,
then the small molecule is included as
an atom level graph of this of this
liant as we've seen before. And then the
surrounding amino acids of this protein
or included as additional nodes. And
then in this model specifically um the
node features of the graph were
initialized using protein language model
embeddings.
And the architecture is quite simple. As
an input, you have these node features,
the edge features, and some global
features. And of course, the
connectivity. And then there's an after
an initial feature transformation, you
have this alternating sequence of um
node feature updates and edge feature
updates. So the nodes are updated based
on their neighbors, including the
embeddings of the edges that connect
them to these neighbors. And then the
edges are updated based on their on the
nodes that they connect. And this
happens like twice. And after every um
node update, we have this uh global
pooling that updates the the global
features
like the global context matrix. And then
in the end uh we have this simple uh
feed forward neural network that um
reduces this uh to a final prediction to
a scalar value that represents the
binding affinity. um prediction
and the prediction of this model um was
quite more accurate than the classical
scoring function I mentioned and uh
it also showed that if you add these
embeddings of the protein language
models to the note features and this
boosts performance and also if you add
embeddings of several protein language
models this kind of has a synergistic um
performance improvement.
Yeah. which is quite interesting and
also shows how these protein language
model latent space representations can
be useful for downstream tasks. Right?
So
we are at the conclusion for graph
neural network section. So they are uh
the GNN's they offer a lot of advantages
for modeling and processing these 3D
objects.
um they can handle the data that is
defined in this irregular domains
without mapping them to a grid and they
are naturally invariant to uh
translation and rotation
and they are also much sparse
representation of a protein or a
molecule than uh the this 3D
representations in in the CNN's
there's also many possibilities for um
data integration and this efficient
update mechanism with graph convolution
that also uses weight sharing.
And so GCN's they usually perform quite
well in tasks where an understanding of
the structure on and the
interconnectivity of the data is
important and they also usually um
perform quite well with a relatively um
low amount low number of parameters.
Yes. Do you have any questions? Next
week we will um first talk shortly about
some challenges in in training models on
biological data and then dive into the
the topic of generative AI for the
design of such small molecules and
proteins.
Thank you for your attention.